hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation
we've finally gotten to the nitty-gritty
of this game we're about ready to face
the xenomorph a rather run away from him
what the hell is that hello oh hello
who's there
someone there is you human well where am
I supposed to go oh oh do I have any
other batteries with me how do I know
okay I just refilled it apparently so I
can't go that way I gotta go this way I
suppose poor Axl I knew exactly that he
was gonna die I knew he was gonna die
very soon but a good thing he didn't get
take me with him that's all good that's
not a good sound
this all-flash is full of not good
sounds
and I know
so when they're in the darkness some of
the air how long is this gonna take
oh we gotta wait for the agonizingly
slow elevator huh semi heartbeat better
not be downhearted Eve oh hello
are you here yet
oh that is so what the hell man what is
your deal as it's designed to be a heart
attack all right
I'm sure nothing to lure inspire Oh
welcome to Sevastopol I'm sure that it's
not gonna follow me die working Joe's a
ruminant Terry Androids but I didn't
read the rest of that the security
access tuner can be used to override
system towards and terminals hey I'm
gonna get that soon it's gonna be even
even more doors find an elevator to seek
some communications okay that sounds
like fun
let's do exactly that no wait so this
thing moves fast now it only went slow
when I called it all right then don't
know I'm going out the same door again
buddy
no one okay I was brave don't try to
scare me I know what I'm doing
okay what is this use rewire to toggle
systems on and off in your surrounding
area limited power supply right hand
screen with mouse to check the position
of local systems okay I have no idea
what you're talking about power
available one unstable system and
speaker system okay I'm guessing that
the unstable system isn't what I wanted
anyway so okay then did that do good
okay good I'm glad
so what now Oh security access tuner I
don't have that I need to find that
where the hell am I gonna find that
hello you you're handsome
what the hell is going on where am I
supposed to go I don't know I don't know
what I'm doing it's so easy to get lost
in this game
where the hell am I going call transit I
guess I don't know what that means call
another transit oh that one's out of
power we're supposed to go I'm supposed
to access to Sikhs and something or
other I thought I came to the Sikhs in
something or other I know what my
objective is find an elevator to see
some communication okay whatever
so I activated a activated some sort of
a speaker on the other side over there
but I don't know what that does what
does it all mean
oh hello huh
no weapons allowed huh good thing I'll
never ever get one in this entire game
all right I'll go this way fine
hit black huh
now that I actually have a flashlight
they have no excuse to actually provide
the minimal lighting the away no this
this goes in a circle isn't it this is
just hide from us Ino morph
that's just it locks something down huh
hey don't shoot dump no [ __ ] Wow Wow Wow
lady what do you mean
woah woah calm down a little bit
what are you doing just trying to be
friendly you go shooting up a storm
fine I'll be friends with nobody but I
will take your nice shiny gun that would
be really nice I just want to be
friendly enough with me what a dumb-dumb
uh-huh yeah oh yes that all makes sense
to me I take the chance okay we find her
tell her oh that's a bit extreme why do
you need to say stuff like that I can
hear you actually no I wasn't
you don't know that I'm just as sneaky
sneaky I'm just a sneaky sneaker No
just gotta lock this off the cha you'll
never get to me so where am I going for
this thing Allah so I need to go over
there wait a minute so I need to go up
that way and be able to go upstairs
there's the only way to get around there
I think anyway this map actually I was
misled because this section wasn't
visible on the map so I need to actually
go place it below or find it so I need
to go back that way but after that I
need to get around them and find my way
upstairs
I don't think running for it would be a
good idea they're probably just gonna
shoot me in the face oh that ain't good
why are there three of you well of
course I'm just a girl
oh not that adds anything new with my
survival techniques but I'm just one
girl against one girl and two guys the
odds are not in my favor please don't
tell me I lit that jet what I didn't
know they saw me I guess I should have
taken a clue oh come on you don't know
me
oh no no no no
no one's here you don't hear nothing mmm
nothing happening over I'll just take
this now what a dumbass
secretary she should have known that I'm
Ripley I'm a badass no she wasn't
you're lying oh I see this probably
loops back around to the other way
well what happened well where'd I go how
about you turn around Oh what oh I see
up sorry
hard for me to see exactly oh no I fell
down okay that's where that's what
happened okay I was confused what ah
this is what I'm talking about
all right then give me all that I need
that craft up a bomb and blow you all
[ __ ] to hell oh is that it I thought
that was gonna be a way around there I
guess I just gotta go everyone says it's
been a secret a secret for special items
so uh you guys still gonna kill me gonna
come oh hello
you didn't see anything
so what am I supposed to do I'm just
gonna be stuck in the center the stent
and stent vent I don't know where they
are I don't know how they behave yet so
I have no idea what I'm doing
but just bear with me okay bear with me
Oh boobie no nothing
god damn is impossible no cuz you're
stupid
oh he's not stupid okay no no no no
you're dumb you're dumb you're dumb
you're dumb dumb dumb you're a dumb dumb
you're dumb dumb dumb dumb you're dumb e
dum dum de dum dum de dum dum oh it's
all of you oh it's there four of you
four of you I'll bring it on come on I'm
afraid you I'm very bad at this
apparently okay you shot me in the face
bro y'all Oh y'all get screwed pump
brewski suck a dong I don't need to hide
screw him
screw that oh come on
well that doe said I'm going down there
no way she's got your hat
it was a bad idea maybe the humans were
the least of my concern hello
oh good come on spread jam all over the
floor oh it's my good friend what's that
wait no is there actually a thing what
what the hell what what the hell
graphical bug okay okay if that could
stop that'd be lovely
I don't know what the hell's going on
now oh that took forever not that you
guys saw it take forever you only saw a
little bit of my failures but that took
a while but I wouldn't make you suffer
through them oh I get a gun yes please
finally I get to get rid of those pesky
no good doer doers and I highly doubt
that I can kill a xenomorph though
probably won't work on any easy no more
so can i I can't aim with this son [ __ ]
does anybody want a piece I didn't think
so
who's it
alright then you know I'm awesome mess
with me far too amazing anybody wants
huh this is - that guy's dead ok we're
fine give me give me give me give me
give me I maxed out on scrap I don't
even know what to do with this crap give
me all your stick well what do I do with
it scrap then revolver med kid I mean I
have scrap so I need that +10 scrap so I
guess I can make another one and that
cost scraps so that would be what I did
right yeah yeah okay that's what that
did so I can take this now okay I just
need to make sure that I have everything
that I need my mission objective that
thing that I need
okay all right Steve August yeah you
sound focused what was that what what
did I just did
oh boy sound good
that sounds actually bad what the hell
is that
what's going on I don't like this what
am i huh
what am i doing what am i doing what am
i doing what am i doing why am I doing
this
why am I doing this oh the point of that
okay
oh hello yes I got a day to sell that's
exactly what I needed
oh boy yay pack the elevator season's so
now I just got to go back because I got
a hack out of here okay no signals oh
hello
what wait what am i I'm not
understanding this oh okay I got it I
get it I get it okay I got that guy okay
so I understand how it works there was
not much information there but my
intelligent brain figured it all out in
no time
how do I get in there I'm guessing the
door that's green that would probably be
it oh by the dead guy
excellent come on come on come on
why aren't you just the worst
it's all about shapes and numbers
knowing what to look for all right let
me in I need I need I need this place
those lovely the carpeting is nice it
even has a hidey hole that I haven't had
a chance to use it all right what else
you got for me
hello Deadman so he wasn't chest bursted
he was just shot and I'm assuming that
I'm gonna need to shot someone anybody
want to get shot anybody better step
back don't know what I'm capable of and
I don't know what I'm getting
Oh a smoke bomb that's handy probably
keep vigilant for spills okay why is
that so creepy
there's that graphical bug again or
maybe that's just the darkness from
amnesia creeping back on me who knows
somebody wanna boil into the face yeah
okay
so how do I disable this security
lockdown of things camera okay oh no no
okay
moving forward what is with the music
shifting like that does that actually
mean something should I be worried about
that or is that just nothingness I have
no idea grab can I make a smoke bomb I
cannot I don't have exactly what I need
too much scrap why is there so much
scrap if I could turn scrap into
something else that'd be lovely but I
need actual items to be able to craft
what I need and then this Oh No there we
go come on come on
ah there you go good enough the good old
noiseless brace I love it one solid
steel there's absolutely nothing oh
hello
oh yeah I'll take this option it looks
safe okay oh good I can still use my gun
in the vent that'll definitely keep me
safe I'm sure
someone okay ethanol humane booze it's
collected booze probably less convenient
to fight xenomorph swab blasted drunk I
got I'm kind of on edge it's weird like
I'm not even worried about the xenomorph
as much as I hey I'm worried about just
another human person trying to kill me
popping out from nowhere how does that
do that I don't know how that disabled
that just did oh come on now
Oh seriously now I keep forgetting that
it when it's green on the center it's
open I think I just see a green button
I'm like oh my god I press that cuz the
mini idiot Oh what do we have here
another crisis that I need to solve wait
a minute not here just here damn it I
was this here I like to turn it off oh
here we go here we go god I gotta gotta
get it um chief the good news is that
I'm about 80% done archiving
sevastopol's internal mail system for
the decommissioning blah blah blah Paulo
but I left basic messaging got mike
tanaka looking on it um ba ba ba ba okay
i'll post one progress desolation
through isolation hey that's the name of
the game something cool about that how
did we get here more importantly where
the billions of dollars of investments
gone my name is Julius Jones I have
lived in seven school for two months
compiling this report okey dokey then
that sounds bad but not that I care
about it no audio logs utility nothing
nothing I would leave as even be here
alright then fine would be like that
that doesn't help me turn all this [ __ ]
off
oh here it's not even green why would I
know oh oh that's not a good sound hi
welcome to the party
oh-oh-oh
what do I do do I run I'm gonna run
oh I'm not running
well then I suppose it was here for good
reason oh yeah the perfect organism
looked like a perfect orgasm for a
savior there well I had a bad feeling
about all this glad that my fields were
fears were all realized so I need to
shut this down huh I don't need it
anyway I can see exactly where I'm going
this is fine that's totally fine it was
just there why didn't it kill me
it probably knew I was there it was
being nice being nice I didn't exactly
turn off the override but I guess
everything's okay now
hope you downstairs is not where I
wanted to go I'm gonna go up up is good
up is nice up is the best keep going up
I guess back to the humans that can lead
it to them and then hopefully it will
kill them and I'll be able to go on my
merry way through the the LOV door done
and done thank you very much God all
this retro technology
man that to the man's really on my back
again
sousaphone man oh you think you're doing
sousaphone man
I don't know what air purification will
do for me but I gotta get by the damn
Italy no more I bet he's gonna be a bit
more trouble than the other guys
where'd he go where is he oh the air
purification it creates smoke okay oh
where is he was he up there
he's my baby right here I behind me oh
you're so right by me I hit as hard as I
can
axel would be proud of me Oh hunt begins
a hunt for me because apparently the
flight recorder doesn't need to be here
how do you even know that Ripley had a
daughter Ripley is a survivor and can
use many things to evade danger okay
apparently okay either way I'll find out
later because oh wait I have not saved
in a while who are you who the hell are
you hello my name is Ripley Amanda
Ripley I need your help you're a robot
but I need you worse
Oh
what the hell is that thing that was a
robot obviously why was it walking
around huh why is it walking around I
they were walking around okay I got that
taking the air that took away two lung
either way I do not like that guy I
don't know who the hell he thinks he is
but he's not the type for me I have not
saved in a long while and I will not
have you kill me before you better let
me save god damn it Oh God Oh God
I'm gonna show you in the face don't
five nights at Freddy's pizza Oh God oh
you're so scary oh you're so creepy
no no you [ __ ] no what do I only rebuild
one bullet at a goddamn time oh god no
no he's gonna kill me
oh he's gonna Oh Oh God okay no no are
you doing what are you doing okay so we
heard what the hell is he
I thought I saw his eyes okay sorry
hi look happy ha why are you so damn
creepy oh my god okay I'm gonna shut up
I'm gonna die Ernie I'm just so damn
creepy oh oh I wasted so much Anna okay
so that explains what they are but
either way I don't like him so thank you
all so much for watching I'm gonna pick
this up in another episode down the road
hope you guys are enjoying the series so
far you guys know about that then yeah
okay alright thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
I got that